The single most important predictor of a successful software design effort
is the extent to which the development team,
staff, have experience on similar problems.
Because we all want to participate in successful projects,
access to that experience is crucial.
One key source of such experience is familiarity with
applicable design solutions.
A design pattern is just that.
A description of a solution to a problem in context.
What this means is that for a given problem, a design pattern provides a way of
solving it, including a description of the issues and tradeoffs involved.
Situations where the solution applies, options that you as a designer have,
consequences of using a solution, and any implementation issues.
Thus, design patterns are reusable design experience.